[تصفيق]
صعبه
برشلونه السريع جناح الديوك المراوث
الجوهره السمراء عثمان ديمبلي صاحب
المسيره الرائعه التي عكرتها وعرقلتها
الاصابات ولد في فرنسا لابوين من اصول
افريقيه يحاولان البحث عن حياه افضل بعيدا
عن القاره السمراء
ظهر شغفه بكره القدم صغيرا وتمرن في نادي
المحلي للهواه ثم حاول لاعب كره الصالات
قبل ان ينضم الى اكاديميه رنيه في الثالثه
عشر من عمره وقع عقده الاحترافيه الاول مع
النادي الفرنسي في 2015 وتالق معه لينتقل
الى بروسيا دورتموند في محطه قصيره قبل ان
يطلبه العملاق الكتل يوناني انتقلت اليه
الى برشلونه في صفقه تاريخيه املا في
تعويض رحيل نيمار الى باريس سان جيرمان
رغم بدايته الواعده مع البلوجرانه الا ان
الاصابات سرعان ما
اطفاته مع الفريق اذ غاب نحو الف يوم خلال
خمس سنوات قضاها في الكامب نو حقق مع
منتخب فرنسا اللقب الاغلى عام 2018 في
روسيا ويسعى مع الديوك للحفاظ عليه في
مونديال قطر 2022 لتحقيق انجاز تاريخي
يتوج به مسيرته
[تصفيق]